[Music]
as so nice to have you here thank you
for making the trip out to the
hinterlands I appreciate it I can't
imagine what your life is like right now
it's just been an absolute whirlwind for
you right it's insane
that's the best way to put it but it's
all good stuff so still a lot of
momentum and adrenaline with it right
it's making it all work but it must be
helping with the typical sort of post
marathon blues that tend to happen right
like you must be riding this crazy wave
of energy yeah for sure I think you take
the time off afterwards and you start
processing like what do I want to do
better well you know if you don't get
the outcome you want you do all that and
I haven't even had time to think about
your days yeah you're too busy you like
throwing baseballs oh yeah and you know
hugging Taylor Swift and stuff like that
like it's so cool to see like mainstream
culture really embrace like the
accomplishment that you have that you
that you made and and really shine a
spotlight on not just marathon running
but like women's marathon running it's
super cool yeah that's been probably the
most surprising part just seeing the
places it's reached but very rewarding
because the women's side was highlighted
this year and you know John Hancock had
this expectation for the American women
to do something really big and they
brought in the great group and um like
it was good to get it done what it was
all about the women's race was almost no
ink on the men's race at all you had to
really search for it it was just all
about the women which was super cool so
can you walk me through it can we talk
about the race are you tired of talking
about it let's talk about it cool
well I think there's so many kind of
interesting entry points into into that
experience but I think you know a good
way to kind of I think launch into it is
to talk about your build-up to the race
because from what I understand it wasn't
like the best sort of training cycle
going into it right like where your
expectations tempered as you line up on
the starting line yeah probably more so
than ever before and a lot it was a lot
of it was the months prior to so last
fall I decided to not do a full marathon
and just um almost step away from
running for a little bit and kind of hit
reset and remind myself why I'm doing
this or if I want to do that and almost
gave myself an out like if you don't
want to do this anymore if you don't
want to be competitive it's okay and
just try this for a while and see if you
can take a step back from the sport
right so you took like five months off
after 17 right yeah it was a cup it was
probably three three months off and then
it was like do I feel like running today
okay great do i and if I didn't that's
great too did you think was there a
possibility at that time that you
thought you might retire not retire but
maybe lower my expectations and pick
different races that maybe were like I
really wanted to win a marathon mm-hmm
and I've been shooting for Boston New
York the games these really big races
and I was like maybe I go do the local
one or maybe I do the Detroit marathon
or the Traverse City one or whatever it
may be just so I could have that
experience of right winning a marathon
because you couldn't well yeah I mean
you you you sort of been a bridesmaid
for throughout your career like yeah
you've been able to kind of ascend at
the top of the sport and yet still
lacked that like one big victory for
sure and so was that part of what kind
of motivated you to get back into
serious training or yeah I mean I I
missed it when I wasn't training and
running out it got to the point where I
started to miss it and that was a good
sign
yeah that is a good sign and then I
started doing races that were short and
just out of my wheelhouse but I could do
a lot of races and compete and you do a
5k every weekend and I was like oh that
this is fun too like I like competing um
and just kind of rebuilt my love that
way but it's not ideal for marathon
training to have a block of
inconsistency right but I think finding
that love for the sport is something
that perhaps is a little bit underrated
in the long run right for sure if you're
hating it every day you could be super
fit or hitting all your marks and your
workouts but your mental game isn't
going to be as dialed as it possibly
could right I mean having the passion
for competing and
for what you're doing you know makes all
the difference if it's a job if it's all
it is is a job like you're not gonna be
great you gotta love the work too but at
some point you it must have clicked in
like okay I'm going to Boston like it's
time to get serious yeah I mean in
Boston's always been the race that got
me fired up so once that was on the
schedule and it was like I'm going to
that race that's when I have an easy or
time preparing and like okay this is
where I visualized myself down Boylston
and you know I've been doing that ever
since I first ran there in 2007 like
picturing yourself winning that race you
need your dog Boston right I did yeah
this is like a heavy thing like why what
I mean I understand but like why why
Boston why not New York why not Berlin
sure
Boston was my debut marathon 2007 it was
similar conditions to this year's not
quite as bad but you know it was a thing
that kept me in the sport I never
thought I was gonna be a professional
runner and I was like well try this
marathon try to qualify for the Olympic
Trials and then move on to the next
thing mm-hmm
but after that race I was like I love
this event
I love 26.2 miles but this course and
with all the history it just captured my
heart and it was like I wanted to see
what I can do here but prior to that I
think I had read that you thought like
marathoning was crazy like it wasn't
like you were always pining to run a
marathon ya know I still think it's
crazy but yeah I wasn't sold on it at
all I mean coming out of in college I
was a person it was like the 10k is
insane there's no way I'm running that
far I'm a 1500 meter runner right then
the coach is like 5k and you're like
fine get talked into the longer stuff
it's interesting looking at the
trajectory of your career because you
were eight you were a good high school
runner and you were a good college
runner but you weren't like a superstar
like I get you got third a pack tens or
something like that at ASU so it wasn't
like oh I'm gonna have a career as a
professional runner and and just rise
all the way to the top yeah is that fair
to say her absolutely
yeah same type of bridesmaid thing where
I was an all-american I was runner-up I
believe it at the high school level at a
state champion ships and but I always
competed and worked out with athletes
who had those big breakthrough
performances like I ran with Amy
Hastings now Craig Victoria Jackson Lee
secular all these people who want
ampionships and I did everything with
them so I was like what am I doing wrong
that I can't have this breakthrough what
am I doing wrong that you know I'm
working out and doing the exact same
stuff as these guys so I have the
ability I'm just haven't got it done yet
mm-hmm so what did what it what do you
think it was that was not allowing you
to get up on that next rung at that time
like what did you learn over the over
the years that has allowed you to come
because like your career is really just
one of a gradual progression upward
right yeah yeah I mean it was patience
just letting my body adapt to the work
and not forcing things but it was also
even in college it was like I wanted it
so bad that I tried to force it and
sometimes you have to like step back and
like again like love what you're doing
and just engage in the process and not
worry about the result like just worry
about what you're doing right now and I
felt like when I would see things
slipping like oh the result is not gonna
happen today I would just like get so
frustrated and find myself giving up on
it so like detaching from those
short-term results and just falling in
love with running itself and kind of
having a longer-term view absolutely
yeah so in the ramp up to Boston you you
take this I mean it sort of appears on
paper like that five months period off
was kind of instrumental right and kind
of rebooting your operating system and
getting you fresh and excited about the
sport again yeah it was definitely
necessary I don't think I could have
gone through another big training block
without having done that I think I would
have been really frustrated and maybe
not even made it to the line
to the start you know but when you go
through the segment I'm a big picture
person I don't think that marathon
result is predicated in the last three
months I say it's Brazil the last you
know 12 months and so I knew I had this
big hole in my build up even though my
build-up to Boston was pretty solid that
makes sense yeah that makes sense but
does that play into your kind of mental
confidence as you line up on the
starting line thinking oh man like this
is like the greatest aggregation of you
know us female marathoners and God knows
how long
right and you're thinking about like the
days that you didn't train yeah yeah no
that was certainly on my mind and I was
like thank goodness it's pouring rain
and there's other factors because you
just expect to be exposed you know like
it but you didn't do all the work this
time mm-hmm but I've also been doing
this for long 13 years as a pro so I
mean it's a kind of a blip on the radar
realize Michigan winters right they play
a huge part I think yeah so so walk me
through like the first you know walk me
through the first part of the race up
until the the big you know sheelane
event yeah I'm I didn't feel great and I
think part of me was thinking this race
was gonna be a stepping stone for the
next one to be really good and so with
the conditions it was like feel it out
mile by mile and if this is gonna be
detrimental to the building process of
the next one like you have to just cut
your losses today yeah I think a lot of
people are gonna have a really hard time
recovering from that race and I was
thinking about that up front which is
not a great attitude to go in with but
it's also as realistic for like the rest
of my career you're thinking about like
a couple more years to do this so I
don't want to blow another year on this
race that could you know just be really
hard to recover fright so there's a
weird mindset to have in a race and
especially that early on but that's
where I was mentally and the pace was
surprised
I thought we were just gonna jog I
thought it was gonna be like 6:30 seven
minutes no one's leading and there was a
couple of East Africans who took turns
off the front like really running in the
five 40s five made five 30s and it's
like this seems really aggressive for
these conditions and so I think that was
also playing into how I felt like this
isn't sustainable mm-hmm and then you
have a little chat with chalene at some
point right yeah and just all of that
feeling and what I might when I might
step off the course if I was going to do
that I just kind of turned to her and
said I I don't think it's my day let me
know if I can do anything for you
because she looked like she was ready to
go everything in the interview is
leading up is like she's fit she's got a
shot to win this she's coming off a
great New York so I'll block the wind if
you need me to do that just tuck in
behind me I mean that's a pretty amazing
gesture you know in a race where it's
all on the line for all of you guys and
I think ultimately that's a big part of
why everybody fell in love with you like
to sacrifice yourself on that level you
know on the global on the global stage
you know for for the you know for the
the betterment of you know American
female marathoners is kind of an amazing
thing but she goes in she does this 13
second pit stop right and then you work
her back up to the group but the pace
was pretty relaxed at that moment right
is that right yeah she she kind of faded
back and was like I need to go to the
bathroom do you think it's a good idea
which is the weirdest conversation ever
mid-race I mean does that happen that
often it doesn't seem to happen and
that's kind of like you're done if you
have to do that right you're out of it
typically yeah yeah so Josh you're
you're in a hotel room by yourself
pacing like in your underwear
pretty visor yeah the TV like when you
see this like what's going through your
mind well I was down in the friends and
family area and it's they have a couple
TVs but you can't hear anything and it's
everyone's talking and the competitors
families are there too so you can't
really get into it and I'm a big sports
fan guy who it does yell at the TV and
stuff and I need to
ya know and I just want to like pace and
do the thing like you're saying and I'm
up there and I was a little bit
surprised I mean we obviously doesn't I
really close and then she's like a
sister of me and we've been working
together since 2011 and she's always
very honest with me and we talk a lot or
we text a ton actually and then but I
had the night before I had been in their
hotel room with Ryan and we kind of for
like two hours just talking about the
plan and how it was gonna go or maybe
not go or mmm the weather and the
factors and we knew that the weather was
gonna be a plus for DES right because
she's so tough between the ears that
other athletes are gonna see it and view
this as a total negative and this is
horrible and look at these conditions in
the headwind in the rain and she's just
super tough right but all that knowing
how the build-up had gone to see her
drop back I was like okay development
new tech did yeah and she didn't she
brought her back up and I guess it's
it's really cool gesture it's all class
yeah something that you don't see it was
you know it was like cycling or
something and the Domus peak going back
and right you know yeah to fold up yeah
but but but you guys aren't technically
teammates no and you're not you'd make
some prior agreement and work for the
betterment of the team leader no in BRT
you know USA national team and Rio
Olympians together and all of it but
yeah there is there's this thing I think
over the last couple years the rivalry
has really turned into friendship which
is really cool with between DES and
shine and she likes it an amazing runner
and we couldn't have been happier with
her New York performance but yeah she
drops back to help her and it was well
this is this is very surprising
I think you called I read somewhere were
you called you called as a gamer yeah so
is there something about the heightened
experience of being in a race that that
allows you to rise to the occasion like
does your motivation come from from that
you know being sort of placed in that
kind of an
Merritt's or like is it about racing
other people is it more internally
driven like what gets you pumped up yeah
I mean I look forward to race day I
think some people get nervous or they're
afraid of it a little bit like that's I
say all the time you do all the training
because the race is the reward that's so
fun to me like I love lining up with
everything on the line like you could
change your life today that's so cool I
mean and I look forward to it and I get
excited about that and I I think that's
why I'm this quote-unquote gamers
because I can't wait to race you know
that's that's what I'm looking forward
to and I like the nervous anxious all of
that and just going out and doing your
thing yeah and and having trained in the
Michigan winters I mean I would imagine
you're thinking how like this is this is
nothing compared to what I'm used to
these Africans are gonna just cave they
don't like to run in the rain at all
yeah they're not even going outside on a
day like that right but you know I've
had days in Michigan there's some
hilarious things that we do there like
that's just a bad idea like that I think
I've run the cold this is a negative 30
windchill you know and coaches like go
out and run and we'll drive by you in
case anyone gets a little too cold and
it's funny you're just like he's an he's
insane this is the dumbest thing there
are treadmills you know and you go out
and you do it you stop whining for a
second like it's actually not that bad
like if you dress right and you have
some people with you I'm like oh like I
didn't die and so it changes your
perspective on what you can handle right
I don't know if it's necessary but so
when you're out when you're out on the
course in Boston is that looping in your
mind like that day that you went out and
and in those kind of conditions for sure
I mean it's like I've done worse than
this I'm not this you know it could get
bad it could be a thing where you have
to step off and say well if it was the
negative 13
I needed coach's car it's there if you
need the out no one's gonna fault you on
a day like that but I was also like I've
done this before it's okay
so after after the you know working
sheelane back up into the pack was there
a moment where you know you things kind
of shifted like a gear shifted and you
thought like actually like feel good
like maybe I can you know take this or
maybe I need to shift my expectation
level um it was a little while later I
actually got her up to the group and
they had started turning off some good
miles just because they knew she was
being dropped and so I we worked back up
and and then I started falling off the
back and I was like oh well that's it
and I goes let's I did the gesture and
we'll see what happens from here but I
thought it was gonna be dropped and I
kind of looked up and it's like I was
closing it down they were kind of
slowing up again and then I I saw Molly
huddle at the front and you know another
American hope who thought was gonna have
a great day and I was like she shouldn't
be leading into the wind like they're
never gonna close up the gap to dashka
if Molly's on the front if they do if
Molly does it she's done like that's her
day and so I just thought I'll go up
front and lead that group as long as I
can and try to get them back up to Tosca
and then see what happens from there
like I can step off sacrifice number two
right yeah for the greater good yeah and
you were able to do that right like you
worked out you worked you you pulled
them back up yeah I really well I
reattached to that group because I'd
been getting dropped and then I went
straight to the front and started
pulling that group towards the leader
and a couple minutes later I looked back
just to make sure like tuck in don't
take any wind on like I'm doing this
it's fine I look back and it was like
three of us that had totally pulled away
from the group like I had completely
splintered it up so I was like well I'm
probably the strongest of all these
people if I'm dropping people I might
feel bad but I'm clearly feeling better
than everybody else so I probably should
stay in it that's super interesting that
that sort of equation between how you
feel and how you're actually doing you
know like your subjective experience
versus objectively what's happening
and being able to like separate from how
you feel and just continue to keep going
yeah I mean I I my college coach you
know who asked us before races all the
time like you ready to go and some
people will respond well I feel kind of
tired or my legs don't feel that papi
he's like I didn't I didn't ask you how
you felt I don't care
you're either ready or you're not and
that's always kind of how I looked at it
like I've done the work I'm ready it
doesn't matter how I feel and I think
because of the conditions I was really
evaluating early on like how do I feel
is just gonna put me in the hole Wang
Ling recovery longevity the whole thing
and so that's the first time I've spent
a lot of time evaluating how I felt and
then by the middle of the race it was
like what am I don't need to do that
right just go back to what works all
right and and around this moment like
what's going on in your head Josh you're
watching this unfold honestly I can
believe it I mean I it's does a story to
tell and she'll tell the whole story at
some point but I'll say this since I've
been working with her I've I'm I'm an
I'm an eternal optimist I always think
Kate she's put in the work super solid
she always has a shot to win the only
there's only been two races that we went
to that I'm like just brought she's
probably not breaking the tape and one
was Berlin in 2013 we decided to go
there cuz this was after her femoral
stress fracture that she had at the
London Games and it was a comeback race
and it was like hey let's just go it's
run under 2:30 just get one under about
so that one was a psych aid let's just
put in the fairway and this was another
one because of you know since really
last summer
it was it was a rough year and she'd had
some good days and some bad days and
some zeros and I just thought this won't
be one where she wins I mean it's
totally fair just just being objective I
mean and how dare you yes no but it was
I was I was I was in disbelief what I
was seeing on TV and my wife's in there
and my buddy Ben is in there
coach that I work with because he wanted
to hear as well and I had the npc gold
on my laptop and I had the local
coverage there and goes commercial I'm
listening the other one you know
watching this going this is amazing
and it wasn't it was just I couldn't
believe how good she looked and she had
had some good days and training you know
as you do but if it was last year last
year going in her build-up was spot on I
thought this doesn't win does can win
this time I was like well we'll see
right and I was just surprised that she
looked so good
she was popping off the ground and
everyone else was starting to fall apart
right really fall apart when when you
dropped she dropped the whole group and
then she kind of like looked back and
you see her looked back and it was like
confused yeah and then she just kept
going and it was like did this this
might be her day how much of that do you
think does is is being able to kind of
stay present and have your mental focus
super attuned versus just the physical
challenges yeah I think so much of its
mental and you can see it in the first
half of the race where I'm doing all
these things that I wouldn't typically
do because of how I feel and I'm worried
about that right if you felt great you
wouldn't but I and I think that helping
people is remove me from thinking about
myself and how I felt and this is hard
it was like let me just do this task and
you become task oriented and then you
have a little bit of success okay I got
Schley into the group that was a win for
the day and you forget about the bigger
picture you just stay in the moment and
do the thing in the moment and as I
started to do that and just focus on the
moment I was in not what was ahead and
how much was left and how bad I felt and
how windy or rainy it was that's when I
started getting into a rhythm I never
felt great but I just it didn't matter
anymore
yeah like taking that focus off of
yourself
I would imagine sort of releases the
pressure a little bit - yeah right and
and maybe there's a little bit of a
greater relaxation where you can kind of
settle into it and you're not really
thinking about you and what you're gonna
do and then suddenly everyone's falling
off the back and you're like oh
absolutely it's so it was kind of at
Mile 20 - right where you just you took
the lead yeah I think it was 22 and
Tosca we closed down the Groupon dashka
and Cheshire from Kenya was a little bit
in front of me I think she held the lead
for about three minutes and then I
passed her and I just felt like if I was
going to pass her I had to go from there
in just because the experience in 2011 I
was like you have to race from here and
you have to race hard and I don't want
to be in a sprint finish on Boylston so
i'ma start dressing now yeah yeah you
have 2011 you lost by two seconds or
something two seconds yeah so is that
going through your mind I would imagine
- right absolutely and and forgive me if
this is an ignorant question but when
you when you take the lead do you know
that you're in the lead or are you still
like is there somebody else still up
there like how do you have that kind of
clarity ya know I knew I was in the lead
I didn't know what was really going on
behind me and like okay we pass Tosca
and I think she's going the wrong way
like she's not gonna come back on me but
you know I'm definitely slowing down I
can tell and my cadence and pace like I
just feel like I'm running really slow
so I'm also thinking it's just a matter
of time before someone who's paced this
better comes charging by me and and then
I also wasn't sure if chess Shera was
able to respond I kind of just thought
she was gonna sit on me and wait for the
cake do you like turn around and check
on that or is it that's not like you
just keep your eyes going forward I I
didn't look I just kind of wanted that
in my head that I was in a really
intense race so that I would keep my
foot on the gas and how much does the
crowd kind of contribute to the energy
yeah it's
in Boston it's amazing they know when an
Americans in front and they're out there
cheering no matter what but when it's
you know an American you can feel it
along the course and you know the crowds
are a little lighter because the weather
but it was still pretty pretty unreal
yeah and and Josh what are you different
when she takes the lead what's going on
with you I just thought I hope that
those early water stations he'll eat
fluid stations that she skipped don't
come back divider this is the thing
she's a consummate pro and I think
something a decision she made before the
gun even went off that morning paid huge
dividends and she was she's at the
church there at the start in Hopkinton
and all the athletes are going out and
they're coming back in and they're
soaked and they're freezing and they're
shivering and she decided not to warm up
right I read that and I was like how you
not warm up well I think we were teasing
wine that and that was part of the
conversation the night before was it's
gonna be slow no one it's gonna be a
race to the back that's what we thought
the pack is gonna go out and everyone's
gonna be a race to the 30 mile an hour
head winds gusts up to over 30 miles an
hour I mean we walked out that morning
and it was literally funny I mean I'm
walking her from the photo-op to the bus
yeah and I have a my Padre hat on and
the hood and the hood flies off and the
Hat on this goes and she just starts
laughing like this is al it was
something out of central casting I mean
literally the rain it's like this just
dumping like someone's dumping buckets
and it was like sideways it's one of
those things if they did it on a set
they'd be like that's too much no one
know yeah yeah it's fine she started
laughing and just didn't see this coming
at all I cuz we talked about her over
the night before but that was the thing
we thought the start was just gonna be a
race to the face to the back and it was
no one's gonna want to leave this start
to finish and go everyone's just gonna
be talking in and so she didn't warm up
but she thought the early miles this
will this would be a great time to warm
up this will be fantastic and it wasn't
that way they kind of pressed but she
was dry and she wore her Brooks jacket
and it was honestly she the clothing she
chose was perfect and she stayed dry she
had a hat on and then she pulled out her
little ear
headband thing right before the start
and kept it dry so I think a lot of that
and something that the reason why a lot
of athletes are having a hard time
recovering now was you're burning
through so much glycogen just to keep
your core temperature up right and so
you're not running that fast you do have
a headwind but your your shiver I mean
you could see people in the pack
watching I had other athletes I'm like
she's really cold I can tell
yeah and it's Dez was very very smart
but when she she'd done all this helping
in Chulainn and Molly and kind of
skipped some bottles which is not Dez I
mean she's the one that grabs her Nathan
bottle and runs with it for a mile until
it's gone I mean it's not she it's you
know four to eight ounces depending on
how hot it is and she has her stuff and
she we drink it to the end it's not like
oh if I'm thirsty or whatever it's this
is what you need for this 5k and having
getting the blood sugar up all of it
it's she's she's a pro but she had
skipped some some early and I'm like
alright you know it's a probably it's
gonna be one of those days and then
she's in the front and I'm thinking
about all these things going like if she
cramps up there's something but I was
just like okay let's go you know and
then it was I was tempering my
expectations so it's like the thing that
we've talked about over burgers and
beers and a hundred times like you're
gonna have your day this is gonna be
amazing in some day it's gonna be you
and you know it's like you start
reflecting back on the London Olympics
and sitting there at the Team USA house
and we're all we all have the
thousand-mile stare like you had to drop
out right maybe like yeah and it's just
a bittersweet thing you're you've
accomplished this big goal and now it's
it's just this is it like and then the
Rio and then it's last summer and it's
like this rollercoaster everything you
dream about this moment so I wasn't
letting myself believe yet that today
was her day mmm des is gonna be the
Boston Marathon champion and that's
forever I mean it's I couldn't allow
myself to go there yet I was hopeful and
I was praying and I was like please let
this be the day but I wasn't
I hadn't committed there yet yeah I'm
just
crash missiles I mean with with that
kind of wind it really is almost like a
cycling race where and you're
sacrificing yourself on the front the
energy output yeah that you're expending
is is so much more significant than the
people that you're pulling so you're
actually doing more work than everyone
else and the question becomes like okay
are you gonna when is this gonna you
know run out what are you gonna run out
of gas right
no that's i ran the last several miles
just in fear and i didn't look back
because i didn't you know i wanted to
feel like I was in a race but it was
also like I knew I skimped on those
early bottles and when you hit the wall
in the marathon it's not like losing
twenty seconds a mile it's a minute 20
seconds done you're not responding
you're not you know coming back and so I
was riding the line of like am I going
too deep in the well how do my legs feel
a little bit shaky like when am i
crossing over into this like I'm doing
the death march home and yeah I was
afraid for that moment because I just
thought it was inevitable after the
things I did early and and you were you
at one moment you were near the end you
were gonna try to take your jacket off
right yeah I think it was 25.5 you go
under a overpass and I was like oh I'll
take the jacket off and you can see me
fidget with it and I kind of bite it my
hands were too cold I was like if
somebody passes me because I'm playing
with my jacket and it's gonna I'll be so
mad at myself forever if I lose the
Boston Marathon because I wanted a
better winners picture like that would
be ridiculous doing something silly
there there's the person you celebrated
too early there's a person who tried to
get a better finishing picture like that
would be horrible
alright so so walk me through like
crossing that finish line I mean what
does that experience like yeah right in
Hereford left on Boylston I made the
left and it was like the heavens just
opened up and the wind gusted even
harder and I think I laughed like
someone
me the other day did you smile when you
turn onto Boylston uh huh
I think I did because it was like again
it was comical how bad the weather was
and it was like there's 600 meters to go
and I'm gonna get one last like from
Mother Nature and I still wasn't sure I
had it in the bag so I felt like I just
needed to run strong and be ready to
respond if someone was on me so that's
how I ran that stretch and when I got
past the Lenox hotel I think that's
where I got out kicked in 2011 that's
when I was like okay I think I think I
got this and then I saw Tom grillak of
the BAA did like a fist pump and you
could start hearing the loud them
announcing like this desert Linden she's
gonna be your Boston champion and I was
like okay no one's I got it and I'm and
that's when I was able to celebrate so
it was a couple strides from the line
and I was in disbelief I was just this
can't be real and it was all the stuff
we talked about you know just seemed
like it was not going to be my ear yeah
that's what makes it so beautiful and
poetic that you had sacrificed yourself
twice you had thought like this is you
know if anything I'm gonna help these
other women mm-hmm and then for it all
the switch and making your day it's just
something really amazing so so Josh Josh
you you you sort of have this famous
embrace with Dez at the finish I like
beating Ryan's yeah here's the thing she
cross okay so she crosses yeah and then
Joanie's there and I mean we're all
we're there and everyone's we're friends
with everyone in Boston we go there
every year we not just in the spring
we're doing other things we the server's
at the hotel know us it's it's like
family so everyone in the BA is there
and they're like grabbing my shoulder
like I think it's gonna happen and like
they told us we have to you know just be
professional but I don't care I just I
got it I loved us and we're all there
and everyone's so excited and she
crosses line and Joanie she's wearing
in the hood you know oh yeah in hugs her
and I was I was like waiting and we were
waiting but Ryan and I had been they're
like this is this is gonna happen and we
had been like hugging and doing whatever
like just waiting for her to come
through we should say just for people
that are listening Ryan as deserts yes
yes yeah so
yeah Ryan Linden great dude
so we're there Joni hugs are and then it
was just pure emotion and we just ran
out and hugged and if I could go back I
would acquiesce and give them like a 10
second my second I don't know something
at least like so there could be a photo
of anything I just I was kind of like
stepping out I was like Ryan right let's
go let's go like this is like this is
the time to do it and we just ran out
and the first thing does said was I
can't believe that just happened
and it was like neither can we like it
was it was and I think I said you were
in this or something and I don't know it
was just I was crying like a baby and it
was I know the work that it takes I was
runner you know that whole thing and
these are the things you dream about
these are the things that get you out of
bed at 5:00 a.m. when the alarm goes off
and it's dark outside and it's you don't
want to go and do the run before the
travel schedule but you go out and you
get your 12 miles in and it's this dream
of one day it's all gonna come together
and it's gonna be my day it's all of
these things that you've seen in your
mind's eye again and again and again and
again and you want that so bad and I've
never I've never been so excited for
someone else to do anything my brother
sent me a text is like dude that's a
Happy's your penny good like I'm like
yeah he's like dude you've never cried
like that in your entire that I am cried
since my my 8 18 month old Rhys born
like before that and I was just overcome
with so much joy and happiness and
because it was a it was a shock too so
that right the difference with like a
child's worth it's it's cool and it's
great you know it's coming
No you know very live in the last month
it's like probably here about like he
was a baby out of me I'm so big and it's
this thing that you can prepare for this
I was not prepared for this I mean it
was just this awesome moment where des
had done the thing uh-huh and she got it
done and she put this stamp on her
career and she'd been you know second in
Chicago and 2010 because of subsequent
disqualifications and then her real
coming-out party was at Boston in 2011
the sprint finished with Caroline : I
really like put her on the map and but
then it's since that time that's after
right after that is when we started
working together and it's like you're
gonna get to the mountaintop
and it's you have to believe that as an
athlete that it's all gonna come
together that I mean does this set it a
hundred times but sport isn't always
fair we all work very hard and you hope
you get that day where it all comes
together and you get this a massive roi
on your lifetime of work and she did it
and I'm just like under the craziest of
circumstances like if you had to scrape
that moment as somebody who's been you
know chasing this dream for so long and
you know had come so close so many times
and you know was climbing that mountain
and just you know like Sisyphus pushing
that rock up the mountain yet time and
time again I mean ultimately for it to
materialize in such a such a strange but
beautiful way I mean you couldn't you
couldn't hope for anything better than
that
ya know I mean I said it after the race
and still applies it's storybook really
is it's um fairytale stuff and but real
life which is what is it you know it's
been you know there's been a number of
weeks that have passed mm-hmm do you
have greater some objectivity on it or a
little more perspective now like what
does it mean to you yeah it's the thing
that I can say I everything was worth it
all the work was worth it you know you
dream of it and you put in the hours you
put in the time again there's no there's
no guarantee everybody works hard
but you believe in yourself and you buy
into this idea every time you line up
for a major I mean again there's been
twice where I thought not I'm not gonna
happen for me this time but since 2011
moving forward if I start a marathon
it's I'm there to try and win like I
believe I can win I've been preparing
for the last three months and saying
well I'm I'm going to be a Boston
Marathon champion so what does the
champion do when you bring that attitude
to everyday you act as if you're already
there and then if it doesn't happen you
have to deal with the aftermath and
regroup and then buy into yourself again
and keep doing that and not give up hope
and so it's a really hard thing to do
and there's no guarantees but yeah it
makes all of that worth it hmm yeah I
think if there's anything if there's
like a word that that really kind of
captures your your career it's just it's
persistence right you even you've got
this phrase keep showing up right you
trademarked it genius in the works and
you I have my computer here cuz I wanted
to read this tweet that you that you
would pinned which is you posted this on
March 5th some days it just flows and I
feel like I'm born to do this other days
it feels like I'm trudging through hell
every day I make the choice to show up
and see what I've got and try to be
better
my advice keep showing up so can you
expound on that a little bit because I
think that's that's applicable to anyone
and everyone who's chasing a goal or a
dream yeah yeah I mean the last 10
months prior to this were really tough
and it was as simple as go out for a run
and don't skip the job just because you
think it might go a certain way or you
don't feel good just go and see and most
of the time you get out the door and it
goes better than you thought
but if you don't do it at all like you
have no chance of getting better you
know it's a zero it's you just look at
it with some kind of regret you know so
there was a lot of days where I didn't
want to get out the door in the past
couple months and it was just show up
just try just see and every time I've
done that you know it's the thing we say
there's no one comes back from Iran and
says I wish I hadn't done that right you
know and so for me it was just give
yourself a chance just try just start
and it's not always gonna go your way
but you don't know unless you show up
mm-hmm
and is that something that that you
apply in other areas of your life I
tried to yeah I mean you know as a
friend and as a wife and all of that
even personal relationships it's just be
there for people you know try and be a
good wife and some days it's hard but
you show up and you do the best you can
and that's how you get better that's how
you learn and it's okay to fail just try
again the next day mm-hmm what is your
relationship with failure or how do you
think about failure yeah I'm actually
incredibly comfortable with it I talk
about it quite often last year was the
big thing where I was like I'm you know
trying to win the Boston Marathon I put
it out there very publicly and
afterwards it didn't happen I said you
know I failed but that's okay and people
like you didn't fail you were amazing
this and that I was like no it's like I
wanted to do this thing and I failed to
do it that's I failed but you don't
failure is an action it's not an
identity we do it all the time and if
you learn from it you get better and
that's how you grow so I think being
super afraid of failure you kind of miss
the point like those are the lessons
that's where you learn the most like you
fail your way to success I feel like we
need a different word like failure has
such a negative connotation and it
scares us yeah if we could come up with
a new word for it that weren't
comfortable with then maybe we'd be more
willing to put ourselves on the line
yeah because we're so afraid of
suffering the consequences of what we
consider to be failure and then beat
ourselves up but that prevents us from
the trying right stepping out and yeah
giving it a go but now that you've won
and there's all this attention on you
and you're throwing baseballs everywhere
like what is it how do you yeah how do
you I mean this is it's a different
experience now for you right like do you
feel like an it is there you feel like
everybody's eyeballs are on you is there
like a different kind of pressure that
you carry with yourself like how do you
it's a new phase right
it is requires a little growth to
acclimate to yeah I honestly I don't
really even processed that yeah like
what's next in how I'm gonna you know
wrap my mind around it but yeah I mean
I'm just kind of writing the high right
now do you say you don't know like a
year you have an idea of what another
race would be or what's the next big
yeah goal or challenge um well I do feel
like there's been a huge sense of relief
like I felt like I needed this highlight
on my resume and I have it now which is
great
but now I can just pick things that I'm
really excited about and find that like
this race have it's been that thing
driving me for so long so I do they'll
be that like post marathon role because
it's like well what is gonna get me that
excited what's gonna get me out the door
now and so I want to find a race that
really speaks to me that way and I'll
most likely do a fall marathon so that's
probably in the works and go from there
just I get to be really picky from here
on here on out just do the stuff that
I'm really passionate about yeah and you
sense that there's an additional
pressure on you now to sort of hold that
line being the Boston victor or do you
try to not think about that there might
be I just don't notice it I think I'm
just gonna go out and keep doing me and
I don't see any big change I think the
American women as a whole are so strong
right now that I won't be surprised if
I'm viewed as an underdog in the future
still because that's just kind of been
what played like my role in this sport
is the underdog
well the American women marathoners are
certainly having a moment right now I
mean it's kind of amazing what's going
on so what's interesting about that is
like why I mean we have chalene you know
when
New York now you winning Boston and a
whole bunch of other outstanding
performances Sarah Hall just had an
amazing run that was like last week or
something like yeah - week segoe I mean
this is unprecedented in recent history
so like what is going on like why now
like what is happening that's
contributing to this level of
performance from American women
marathoners yeah I think we're getting
more support with companies and
endorsements and you can make a career
out of running and so that keeps people
in it longer you can develop and I think
two people are switching to the marathon
earlier you know it's like it's just
really great event that you can have a
career in it used to be as soon as you
got too slow for the track then you had
to go the marathon and that was where
the old slow folks when where the
marathons gonna it's it's getting sexy
you know people want to be there they
see the attention around this big event
and they're really selling it and the
success is gonna breed success and the
more opportunities we have and the more
you can make a career out of it
the longer people can stay in it so yeah
and also to see people performing at
such a high level in their mid to late
30s I mean you know that's just it's
it's amazing and that's purely a
function of the people being able to
support themselves doing it yeah I'm
Sebastian what is the role of of your
coach and kind of coaching in general in
in your you know your your performances
how does that work for you
yeah I've been with the same coaches for
my entire pro career and so like we got
I do the same basically marathon
build-up every time and then as I've
done more and more I know what I need
from it or what I need to tweak and so
it's more of a collaboration now not
like here's what you're doing and you
know show up this day and this time and
do these paces it's like I'll I would
like that here I would like that there
and it's it's kind of a team effort that
way I would say has the training changed
or evolved over the years or do you kind
of do basically the same thing you've
always been doing it's very very similar
yeah
and the big things that I think I do
better than a number of my teammates in
which why I've I believe I've had more
success with the training than some
other people have is balancing in speed
work and breaks and then marathon
training and you know knowing you can't
keep doing the same cycle over and over
you have to go back to the track or you
have to get into the shorter 5k races do
some cross country and it's knowing when
to put those things in and tap into the
strength or tap into the speed so in
other words a lot of other people aren't
doing the track work and the speed work
yeah as much as you think I should
people like to do what they're really
good at which makes a lot of sense but
sometimes you got to go practice the
thing that you suck at and get better at
it so that it helps you you know with
the part the strength stuff that you're
good at or whatever it is it's
interesting here you set up because you
know I can understand that for sort of
couch you know sort of couch cruiser
marathoners who are just trying to break
for hours or whatever like they don't
need to do a lot of track work but at
your level you guys are running so fast
that I would imagine everybody's at the
track you'd be surprised
really well it's interesting yeah and
and also to hear you I mean that it
sounds like you're you're kind of a
traditionalist right like okay here's
what works this is kind of what's always
worked in an age when it seems like
every month like there's a new thing
like here's a new diet or here's a new
recovery tool or here you know all those
long runs you don't need to do that you
should be doing this instead like are
you able to just tune all that out and
just say this is what works I listen to
my coach I know what I need
yeah everyone wants a hack right but
running is always going to make you a
better runner and I just I think it's
super simple you go out and you log the
miles and like rest is you know recovery
is getting good sleep a massage that's
it's I mean you know they get cute what
about like compression socks and one of
those Norma tech boots and all that kind
of stuff do you do all it like do you do
any of that kind of thing um I'll flirt
with that stuff I mean not mind the
socks especially if it's cold I can feel
they don't like they don't like
compression socks too much right yeah
another great story
was it chrisley ada went out to train
with you guys up in Mammoth and he shows
up and compression shot socks and you
guys are laughing out I'm sure they just
were laughing and and Josh as as
somebody who was an extraordinary runner
in your own right 50k was world record
or American record American America does
that record still stand it does it does
wow that's amazing man are you able to
bifurcate your role as manager from from
sort of talking to her about actual
coaching type stuff yeah I do my best to
stay on lane you know and I let the
coaches coach and I do i agent yeah so
it's uh but certainly I do have strong
opinions on on at all you know like
someone like Dez I mean we talk a lot
and you know it's she's not asking me
for training advice but it's like yeah
we have discussions all the time or like
maybe this product or do this or this is
what worked for me we were I was
competing when I started representing
him I mean we both competed at the 2012
marathon trials right so it's yeah this
is the same we were we had mutual
sponsors and this thing and we I knew
what worked for me and I knew what my
training partners were doing and very
fast people and their own right and Ryan
halls and meb and we have this group
it's you learn anecdotally but hey this
is what has worked here and this is what
you should maybe try and Dez's does a
student you know so she's always open to
I don't know how many different mixes
you've had in your bottles over but it's
simple
yeah it's it's but she knows what works
you know and she goes with it but ya
know I I try and let the coaches coach
well it's I think it's good to have his
perspective to like when we're filling
in schedules like what races make sense
and you know there's some people say
well there's a gajillion dollars you're
doing in right you know do all of these
races and you could sign up for
something every weekend but Josh knows
that when I'm picking it's these ones
work and this is why
I and like you know it's we're actually
what we're really getting ready for is
here and you don't want to compromise
that because of all these other things
and so it's good to have someone who's
competed and knows that balance of like
appearances racing and then the big day
and how to schedule it all in and I like
this idea of being in partnership with
your coach right because you have to
take responsibility for yourself and
it's somebody who's competing at such a
high level for so long like you have to
really own what works for you and be in
a relationship with a coach where that's
that's functional right yeah it can't be
one-sided it's you telling me what to do
at this point I've done so many segments
it's like I know that doesn't work right
you know and they trust me enough to
make those changes and say okay like you
do what you think is best but you moved
to Michigan to be part of this team
right the Hansen's Brooks and so when
you're training are like how much of it
is you going out and just running by
yourself versus doing it with teammates
yeah it's kind of evolved over the years
it was like living the house with the
group and every day 8 a.m. you know we
all do the same run and work out
together and so on and so forth
we've had a lot of people move on to
different careers I'm obviously like one
of the oldest one of the oldest on the
team and we have a younger squad that's
on the track and you know their long
runs 10 miles and I'm David 20 and so it
doesn't quite match up as well now but I
still have teammates and then we've also
kind of have like satellite athletes who
live here here here we're all in the
same group but that gives me a little
more freedom to say okay I want to spend
some time in the northern part of the
state and just like pull up and run and
not you know deal with the other stuff
and so it's a little more flexibility
and I can do a lot on my own now - where
do you go in the northern part of the
state we spend a lot of time in
Charlevoix Charleroi and Traverse City
so we have a nice house on Lake Michigan
yeah it's it's quiet up there and get in
the dirt roads and not see a car for a
20-mile run I am originally from
Michigan okay
and all my extended families from
Michigan and we used to spend all our
summers on Lake Michigan my parents had
a house near Sleeping Bear Dunes here
near Traverse I'm like it's amazing
training up there it's a hidden gem so I
hope not too many people see this and
then run over the town with training
camps yeah we California it's awesome
Josh should be better ever been up there
I have one time yeah that's pretty
beautiful there's nice that's cool so
what about what about Ryan your husband
do you ever train with him I do actually
we matched up really well when he was
just doing marathons and so in Chicago
2010 he had a really great segment it
was ready to run 224 I had a rocky
segment it was like I think I can run to
27 to 26 so we had totally different
race plans and I see him at like mile 22
he's going the wrong way I'm running up
on him and I out kicked him all right
you beat him I like one second second
two seconds like what you love me so you
guys so you'll go out and train with him
a little bit yeah he's moved into the
ironman world so that's his thing and
but he can still run of me right and and
on your big weeks like what's the
mileage look like I'll get up to around
130 you don't think I can a lot of time
uh-huh have you ever so you had that
injury in London right but other than
that have you been able to avoid big
injuries that's the biggest and I've had
like little niggles here and there stuff
that I'll catch early and it's like take
a couple weeks off and you get to go so
I've been very lucky right
what uh what scares you what's out there
that like freaks you out like physically
or like like the fear of not knowing
what's next I guess anything I mean on
the one level like is there an event
that you're really intimidated by that
you're scared to do and then also just
life stuff yeah um I'm always intrigued
by the Ironman like here like switching
over you know
but I'm a sinker I go out for the
swimmers that's right Wayne they make it
easy yeah I like you watch they put
together the video at the end it's all
inspirational I get the awards any like
is this beautiful these people are so
tough and like I want to do that and
then I see my husband's like training
schedule and I'm like that's horrible
there's no way well they they I mean the
NBC coverage is so beautifully put
together it looks like just a big
romance the reality of it I think is a
little bit different well that's
interesting
maybe a little post career Ironman
Express yeah yeah yeah you get to wear
compression socks that's right
that's why it's more for the fashion for
there's a lot of like you know amateur
athletes that listen to this show so I
thought it'd be interesting to share
like some insights that somebody who's
been around the sport for so long I'm
sure you see because what you do is it's
very rare in the sense that you're
participating in the same event with all
the amateurs right as a professional
like that only exists in a few sports
like triathlon and running what are the
things that you see if you do like that
you see amateur athletes doing where
you're like what are they doing don't
they know like if they just did this it
would be so much easier and better yeah
I mean I think it goes back to the hacks
like everyone wants the quickest way to
the PR and then want the fastest shoes
or the lightest this I'm not gonna pick
on the triathletes but like the gear you
can pick on them okay I'm gonna pick on
the chance now the gear is like huge
it's like let me shave something here
let me lose a couple pounds there and
like just train like it's so simple
especially if I'm back to running it's
just it's right foot left foot right
foot left foot repeat we all do it put
in the time do the work and you're gonna
see the improvements don't try to do the
shortcut just expect for it to take some
time I have to do the work man most
people they would they want to talk
about the shoes and the watch and the
heartrate monitor and all that kind of
stuff and it's like just go out and do
it right
but when you're at a race like is there
other specific things that you see
people doing like why are they going out
and running really hard the day before
the race you see a lot of that for sure
I don't know maybe Expo stuff like
looking for something new at the expo to
help them on race day and you're like no
don't nothing new nothing new today use
that for the next one yeah I think
that's I don't know most people have a
pretty dialed but a Boston I mean you
get to a Boston and those people are
probably you know they're like yeah yeah
same thing like a Kona like they're
pretty good they know what they're doing
for the most part do you have like any
kind of rituals around your mental
preparation do you do a visualization or
do you when you're running are you you
know sort of rehearsing what it's gonna
be like yeah I think it's not like a
scheduled or planned thing but I think I
just naturally do that like well I'll
get out in the middle of a run and
you're picturing breaking the tape but
not like a routine every week where I go
into it and like I have to do this or
that but uh and then pretty race it the
same thing I am alright a race plan like
an actual physical race plan pen and
paper and write out how I see the day
going and the things you know it's based
on what I can do not you know what
people around me are doing so you can
control the controllables and I write it
out on a piece of paper and then I have
this thing to look at afterwards and say
oh I didn't do that or I did do this and
also when you're on the course it's
instead of evaluating how you're feeling
you just go what's next on the plan what
am I supposed to do next so it takes
away that bargaining moment or you're
like well I feel bad I should slow down
it's just uh you know bargain because
you have the next thing on your plan to
do yeah I think I read that that when
you the first time you did Boston when
you when you lost by two seconds you
said like that was the first time that
you had lost it because you had
rehearsed it yes so frequently in your
mind winning it that you were like wait
no
I'm supposed to win heartbreaking
but I think that that you know what I
take away from that what you just said
is this idea that that it goes back to
how you how you're feeling versus how
you're actually doing right somebody
who's not as mentally tough or as
mentally well rehearsed when they don't
feel well or they're like I'm off my
game that can just crack them right and
then the race is over but to understand
like okay I don't feel good now but you
know there's a long way to go and many
things can change to be able to stay
present mm-hmm you know and focused on
on the bigger goal I mean I think what
what you experienced in Boston is a
perfect testament to that
yeah there's it's such a long race
there's so many ups and downs that
you're gonna feel a million a million
different ways and if you let the first
bump in the road derail you I mean you
know a long run home cuz you'll pull out
of it and you'll be in a slump again and
it's just how those races go yeah what
uh what what do you think is driving you
like what's where's the motivation calm
like what's what's the internal engine
that's propelling you through this
adventure I've always been motivated to
find out how good I can be you know and
I want to know how fast I can run and
how well I can compete and that's why I
go to the biggest races instead of
trying to win the smaller race like
those big races push you because there's
the best people there and if you want to
find out how good you can be you have to
line up with people who can pull you to
that spot and um you know and that's
making the decisions to show up every
day is I want to look at the zero in the
logbook and go well now there's a
question like I didn't do all the work
so what if you had how good could you be
um and so it's it's just finding out
what I've got and how far I can take
myself in the sport so it's really
internal absolutely it's you measuring
yourself against yourself yep 100
percent yeah yeah and how do you
maintain that when there's like when
you're in a race and
you're a gamer how do you stay within
yourself when there's all the jockeying
with the other athletes like do you let
go of that and you're just racing or are
you still like okay I have my plan I
gotta stick to my plan
yeah I think it's balancing the two and
knowing when it's appropriate to race
what moves are appropriate to respond to
what's totally out of your wheelhouse
and that's all you know the Josh always
says the first 20 with your head the
last six miles with your heart and you
know that first 20 miles you have to
make race decisions based on your
ability and everything you've seen in
the the preparation and no one to
respond and when not in the last 10 K
you just go from the heart you now
respond to whatever you can respond to
you dig as deep as you can dig yeah and
that's just I feel like a lifetime of
practice racing right Josh if I had to
ask you which I'm going down what what
makes what makes does great like what is
it about des that that maybe people
don't don't really understand I think or
one it's who she is outside of running
she does that she has been on this quest
to find out how good she can be and the
race isn't the verdict on her I think
she has very good balance for someone at
her level a lot of a lot of athletes it
at her level and when I was competing
they take their question you know do I
have what it takes to their job to their
performance every single bad workout
they're crushed you can't talk to them
it's man I hope the next workout cause
well so I can talk to this guy and or I
hope the race goes well so we can still
go out and have a good meal after and is
she disappointed after London and from
all stress fracture in the hole yes sure
it's like you want them to care but she
does have this balance and she never
lets herself sulk too long you know I
think the last year was probably the
toughest that I've ever experienced
with any athlete just the stuff she was
going through and the ups and downs but
on race day outside of that between the
curbs
she is so tough she she talked about the
last 10k running it with your heart she
knows how to put herself into the pain
cave and be tougher than she's ever been
physically she'd be stronger than she's
ever been mentally and she's gonna give
herself every chance to succeed she does
a fantastic job of race day execution
that's the thing a lot of athletes they
do this same buildup amateurs all the
way up to the pros you look at it and
then they totally do not execute on race
day and that's the thing you look at it
and you know I do a lot of announcing
for NBC and whatever when we go to these
races and you hear these pre-race
comments and the guys are like well I
just plan on going through the half and
6230 and also up on the back half but
I'm pretty sure that I can still PR and
it's like the data doesn't show that
like you want to run even there's no
such thing as baking time in the
marathon if if you want to run three
hours being five minutes ahead of pace
that half way is not awesome like that
that's bad you want to you want to run
even the fastest times in history or
even our negative splits second half
faster does does not mess up the race
day execution and typically you know
it's like we talked about the missing
bottles and then I mean that's the thing
it was like that was the surprising part
the schlanger
was like yeah well that's cute or
whatever but the missing bottles of my
well alright matters I don't know there
was nothing about that race that I think
was about a race execution plan all
right
no that minute you start and go warm up
no you know I mean it was a total
anomaly I mean it's just you're just
this is not des but she executes on race
day really well and obviously it worked
out yeah Anisa
is there anything like with this white
hot spotlight on you right now and you
having to run around and do all kinds of
interviews and stuff like that is there
any part of you does it you feel like is
is being missed or misinterpreted or the
people like people are not understanding
about this whole thing or you in general
no I mean I think I'm have always been
very
be open and honest and genuine and so I
feel like it's always been received
correctly
I don't know Josh what do you think okay
this is the part of the podcast yeah the
cool thing about does is she is super
comfortable in her own skin mm-hmm and
she's not the one that gets all makeup
and stuff when she goes to run or to an
appearance or whatever and we go to
billboards and my god you have 45
minutes scheduled for hair and makeup
and she's like what you know and she
looked beautiful and is amazing in there
but everyone was like oh my gosh she
looks amazing you know but it's it's cuz
this is her this it she's totally
comfortable in her own skin and she
speaks her mind and she always has and
it's what makes her endearing and it's
why people what you see is what you get
theirs does doesn't pull any punches and
she's not putting out the facade and
this it's oh this is who I need to be on
social or whatever in this highlight
reel of my life and it's this is this is
what's going on it's her pin tweet it's
this is me being honest and this is who
I am and so there's with a lot of people
is like well there's a lot you don't
know but I can't talk about it you you
know but with her there's it's um she is
super comfortable in her own skin and
that's what makes her so cool and that's
why everybody loves her I just wanted to
Pat in the back so you guys were in San
Diego yesterday yeah right and you did
this run rock and roll race and I saw
the tweets there was like an
active-shooter so what was going what
happened
it was pretty unclear like it was here's
this thing going on by the marathon and
then as people get more information it's
like it wasn't at the marathon it wasn't
towards the marathon and it was near the
marathon but just in case mm-hmm and so
I don't need it what down the course
they we went to get brunch this really
great place and we had these massive
omelets and it was super and we're
walking back and we get back to the west
and and we see all of these ambulances
like it was like six of them lined up
I'm going what's going on we're not near
the racecourse and I asked Tara Welling
Pro that was there that it raised I said
what's going on so I was
an active shooter situation I'm like
what I'm like you society I said what
are you doing so I'm waiting for my mom
I said you need to wait inside yeah like
have her text you like I was I was
surprised they didn't have staff saying
everyone inside I mean it was we didn't
know what was going on
so immediately we're gonna go take a nap
but we went up to the barber like can
you turn on the local news and we're
trying to find it on Twitter and we're
looking I'm like I'm just gonna say
everyone should go inside like I don't
know and we put a link to NBC San Diego
link when is this is gonna be updated
but apparently someone there was an
incident and then they shut down the
race course and cuz I mean it's yeah you
don't know you don't know I mean it
turned out that it was an altercation
that had nothing to do with race right
right but like huh you know the chaos
that can ensue in the midst of that and
and you know being being like Boston
were you guys in Boston was that one of
the years that you raced I didn't really
say all right um
were you there Josh yeah I was right and
so the kind of you know residual
experience of having been in there when
that happened I would and when when
something like that occurs you're like
it's the thing is DEFCON five everyone's
trying to get the news but no one has
the news and you don't know what to
believe or what to like put out there if
it's gonna create more fear it's just
like let's pause and like figure out
what's really going on but also you
don't want people being set up to be in
a really normalization so if you can get
someone out of harm's way then you do it
but there is this social media 24-hour
news cycle people want to be first
rather than right and so there is this
balance of like is this legit is what's
in like it is is confirmed and okay we
should send something out but it's yeah
you just pray to God that nothing like
that ever happens again at a race right
what in in Boston this year I mean what
is it like around the finish line do
they have added security and all that
kind of thing or yeah I mean I we
noticed it the year after was a totally
different world and I think they have it
down so well David McCullough McGilvery
and his team and the BAA
they're pros they've been doing this for
so long and I think the response on that
day was great you know it's just a
horrible thing but they handled it very
well and then they got even better so
it's different but I don't ever feel
uncomfortable out there yeah that's such
a crazy thing right and you're so
exposed because the course is 26 miles
long I mean it's like if somebody's
motivated you know there's nothing
there's really nothing you could do
there's no way to police 26 miles of
course particularly on a point-to-point
the way that in Boston is yeah and yes
they do it as much as they possibly can
for sure so des are you training at all
right now
break when I can I've been traveling
around quite a bit and it's just trying
to get something in everyday and then if
it can be quality that's great but I'll
start really diving back into things
probably a couple weeks here huh yeah
I've got a few more baseballs you want
to throw a straight yeah what do you got
do you have some cool stuff on the
schedule coming up yeah I mean we're
going to New York this week for the mini
10k and global running days a Wednesday
not to date the podcast but she is gonna
be doing some stuff there at the New
York Stock Exchange and some different
things and appearances and whatnot and
then going to the BAA 10k oh cool at the
end of the month so she gets she gets
what one weekend off yesterday we get to
Train yeah exactly she did run two hours
yesterday the painter so that was when
you weren't going I think I'm on Twitter
I saw that yeah it's very cool one of
the things that I always kind of talk
about on the podcast as a father of two
daughters you know people say oh there's
no great female role models out there
and I think there are lots of them
there's amazing women doing amazing
things it's just that we don't do a very
good job of really celebrating them to
the extent that that we should and we're
you know focused on the Kardashians what
have you so now as this you know newly
anointed
female role model like you how do you
think about how do you think about what
you do and who you are and the impact
that you can have on young girls yeah I
mean it's definitely really cool to know
that we have the spotlight on our sport
and I don't think I'm alone in it at all
I do think that the American women
distance runners right now there's a ton
of faces that are doing great things and
are really inspiring and that's the
whole thing is if you can make this
somewhat selfish sport connect and
matter and get somebody to buy a pair of
shoes get a girl to decide to learn take
up running and it's a lifetime activity
you can change a life which is really
cool I don't see myself changing how I
do things it's just me being me and I
hope that there are really great parts
that people will you know want to
emulate or you know be inspired by and
but I don't not actively trying to say
hey I want to change this or change
right I guess it's a lead by examining
more than who you are you know just you
being you and what you do is really
inspiring and it's powerful and and I
think it was really cool how the media
really did you know latch onto your
story and and it was so broadly told and
in such a beautiful way and I think it's
just it's it's really cool for for our
culture right now you know it's in crazy
times right we need more stories like
you so it was it was so great that that
it unfolded in that beautiful way and I
think that the legacy of that you know
will continue to be told for a long time
and I think you're in a position to
really influence a lot of young girls in
a really positive way and I think that's
super exciting yeah that's pretty cool
yeah it is
so if there is a young girl listening to
this who's like she seems cool what do
you want to say to that person um I
would say figure out what you're about
figure out what you want get comfortable
with yourself you know
and it might not be running whatever it
is that you like to do do it with all
your heart and dream big and give
yourself a chance you know show up and
do whatever it takes and um yeah just
love what you do like I think that's why
I've gotten this far and running it's
just loving what I do and it makes you
know it's like kind of a cliche but if
you love your job you're never gonna
work a day in your life type thing but I
it's true yeah I mean I think most
people don't do a good enough job of
asking themselves that that very
question because we're not we're not
sort of culturally attuned to to follow
our hearts in the way that I think that
that we should be and I think if
everybody loved what they did or had the
courage to you know pull on that thread
and follow it and I think the world
would be a better place so I think
that's beautiful now he gets a good way
to wrap it up it sounds great
yeah so thank you so much you are an
inspiration I really appreciate you
coming to talk to me today if people
want to find you online what's the best
place for them to do that I'm on twitter
at des des underscore Linden Li nd en
and it's a Instagram as well
I put some fun pictures out yeah and
Josh what about you and Josh Cox yeah
but just follow Tony for that hog no
it's cool
I really appreciate your God's time
today thanks a lot thank you thank you
[Music]
you